jean yves langenier
60 et hazan
c'est conseil départemental
quand on est au top et je suis membre de
la commission permanente
il est lu
de la commune du port tiens ce contenu
donc c'est une commune canton comme on
dit et donc je suis j'ai été lue
récemment
avec magnum isabelle errot vidal
conseillers départementaux doublons
je crois que
à la réunion actuellement tout est
prioritaire on est confronté à une
situation hors norme tant en matière de
chômage de créer du logement de violence
tout est à traiter et sur le plan social
puisque c'est là la compétence
principale du développement je pense
qu'il ya un certain nombre de volets on
était bien dans le domaine des personnes
âgées handicapées g chez les jeunes pour
le transport des élèves des collégiens
parc social du département je pense que
tous ces domaines c'est des domaines
importants sur lesquels il faut déployer
toutes les énergies et toutes les
compétences qu'on peut avoir pour
essayer d'améliorer la situation
d'ensemble de la population
le département un rôle majeur dans ce
sens et on est dans un contexte
difficile aujourd'hui pas seulement au
plan social économique mais également
sur le plan environnemental la réunion
comme partout ailleurs ont dû confronter
on sera de plus en plus confrontés au
problème conséquences du changement
climatique et je pense que le
département a un rôle important d'une
part sur le plan de la conscientisation
je pense qu'il faut qu'on arrive à faire
en sorte que toute notre population
soient sensibles à ces grandes c est que
notre population sport consciente et
participative de façon à essayer de
faire face aux conséquences des
problématiques environnementales que
nous devons à traiter dans le futur et
puis le département les propriétaires de
forêts départementaux domaniale c'est
extrêmement important dans notre vie
puisque je crois que les réunionnais
comme tout à chacun adore sortir adore
se promener adore la nature et le
département sont encore propriétaires de
tous ces espaces naturels sensibles le
département un rôle pour améliorer
l'accueil pour faire en sorte que le
rugby mais aussi parce que bien et
respecte l'environnement qui est notre
principale richesse sur le banc heureux
de mon talent à la rue donc je crois que
le dépassement un rôle de premier plan
joué en matière d'amélioration de la
qualité de vie et la qualité confort de
toutes nos populations